I saw oh they had the justice Smollett
and justice smile at that case has
gotten wild I talked about it before and
and my thing the bottom line thing for
me with the justice Smollett that knew
this thing was a fiction al was and
nobody robbing somebody for a damn
Subway sandwich you know that Jesse
nobody's robbing somebody for a Subway
sandwich now somebody I'll see somebody
you know [ __ ] I might tighten somebody
up a little bit for a damn Jimmy John
you know or I might have to put somebody
in a sleep in a sleeper hold for uh you
know for one of them yet him Turkey at
Toms from Jimmy John but when just as
small it's a you know couple ah racial
the haters or you know people attack I
mean and he made it sound like damn John
Wilkes Booth attacked him it was just so
core it just it was too racist bro Mike
dude nobody's that racist anymore
you know people's a little racist here
and there bro but nobody [ __ ] doing
all of that I mean he made it I mean
this dude it was too much but the bottom
line fact you know that that got me was
nobody [ __ ] ransacking somebody's ass
in the middle of the night in sub-zero
temperatures for a Subway sandwich bro
maybe like I said for that Jimmy John or
even for a Jersey Mike even though they
got that sweaty meeting and you know
that [ __ ] Jersey Mike y'all dealing that
sweaty meat what are y'all doing huh you
know making him pigs nervous and stuff
them animals nervous for you killing
them cuz they got sweating the meat and
why do they have sweating the meat so
but um but now I feel kind of bad for
the kid you know like I feel bad for the
guy makes you wonder well why would
somebody do that why would somebody make
up this thing about you know it's just
too much too many people who struggled
too much with racial stuff to to use
that all to your benefit to I mean we
all know
hey why it's wrong for him to do that
you know but a lot goes and you're just
starting a lot of units that we don't
need that kind of hate we don't need
that but I feel for the kid too you know
I feel for why somebody would do that
what makes them you know what may you
know it's just some acceptance he needs
some acceptance you know he it seemed
like he definitely had some real ego
infection because then he made a video
the young man just as Smollett and dude
[ __ ] just say your name's Jesse bro
let's come on dude Jesus man or jezus as
he would say but the thing you you you
know you can't just too much is going
into that too much is going into trying
to get race into a better place and and
I think it is overall and then you have
this kind of stuff and that's just ego
that's just him what no you know it's
ego and our egos can be very dangerous
for all of us you know for all of us not
just this young fella and I feel for him
because that's now that's a tough spot
to be in and it looks like he's doubling
down with attorneys and gonna stick to
his story and who knows maybe you know I
just that's just a lot man and he called
it he and then he made a follow-up video
calling himself the gay to POC just like
come on man get over yourself you need
to buy a cardboard cutout of yourself
and lay it on the ground and then step
over it and get over yourself
but you know what then lawyers get
involved and we never know after that
like we never you know it'll all be you
know I mean Willie ever you know I just
hope if he makes a statement he tries to
let us know when to what he was feeling
and why he did that did he feel like you
know scared did he feel you must have
thought he was losing his job like why
do people work why are we doing what we
do you know and that's why
why do I do what I do you know what is
behind it why do people or I try to you
know I don't always I mean I you know I
mean cuz we're all just out here
we all out here it's just the devil and
God and us out here and so I wonder
about that but ain't nobody [ __ ]
stealing a damn son Brooke how you even
imagine rolling up on somebody for what
for a [ __ ] meet but it would do to
imagine if you beat somebody up in the
snow and they got a damn cold and it's
just a cold sandwich it ain't even that
warm meatball sub that [ __ ] MB jaw
filler bruh dude I'd be so I'd beat the
person up again just for not ordering a
hot sandwich in cold weather can you
imagine you beat some my you beat the
you know you beat the sandwich out of
somebody and it's just uh just nothing
you know now if it's a per Manny
Brothers dude
Kim do it yeah [ __ ] huh
brah you know I'm saying I throw a
grenade into a [ __ ] I throw a grenade
into uh into a house party for a damper
Manny brothers do Gang Gang bro good
evening good afternoon and other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one